foreign
culture is a real phenomenon and a
dangerous one lives have been destroyed
by it history has been Rewritten a
generation of ridiculous cry bullies
have been empowered in all the worst
ways imaginable cancel culture is an
epidemic
but cancer culture is also at this point
a slogan that makes for fodder for
three-minute Fox News segments along
with being a real problem it is as well
cheap and easy Boomer bait cancer
culture is bad
and you can always earn cheap Applause
by saying cancel culture is bad this
doesn't mean that we should stop saying
it or that we should stop fighting
cancer culture but it does mean that
when someone claims that something or
someone is being canceled we should stop
and take a moment to scrutinize those
claims because you know the fight
against cancer culture because it makes
for a quick Fox News segment and because
there is Applause to be earned by
pretending you're a part of the fight
that means there's an incentive to
pretend that you are the victim of
cancel culture or that something else is
the victim against culture when in fact
that isn't true
now the good news is that it only takes
a little bit of critical thinking a
little bit of digging to sort through
all this and get to the truth and that
brings us to the latest alleged cancel
culture victim the 70s rock band Queen
the headlines started pouring in Fast
and Furious yesterday Queen has been
canceled the wolf mob is at it again
specifically one Queen song called Fat
Bottom Girls has fallen prey to
political correctness we're told as the
independent reports quote Queen fans
left fuming as Fat Bottom Girls left off
Greatest Hits release
the sun declares Queen uh Queen drops
classic track from Greatest Hits due to
woke cancel culture The Daily Mail says
a classic Queen song Fat Bottom Girls is
mysteriously dropped from the group's
new greatest hits collection the
conservative website the Federalists had
this headline amid era of body
positivity Queens Fat Bottom Girls gets
canceled
meanwhile the New York Post in an
editorial pleaded don't stop Fat Bottom
Girls from making the rocking world go
round
right on cue social media was flooded
with post lamenting the cancellation of
Queen and their classic song about girls
with fat bottoms the topic was trending
on Twitter all day long and nearly
everyone seemed to agree that this
cancellation was outrageous ludicrous
orwellian
many conservative pundits including ones
that I like and respect Express their
outrage over this
and of course Fox News got in on the
action in their article they claim that
uh quote legendary rock band Queen's
1978 classic Fat Bottom Girls has become
cancel culture's latest victim
and here's how they how Fox News covered
the issue in a segment yesterday watch
gotta get your thoughts on this just so
I can say this line We Will We Will woke
you that's the headline in the Daily
Mail as Queen's classic song Fat
Bottomed Girls mysteriously goes missing
from the group's new greatest hits
collection Joe your reaction
I mean you watched that movie uh Robbie
Malek and it was a great portrayal of
Queen and how they came to be one of the
biggest bands of the 70s and they were
Politically Incorrect at the time you
remember the producers uh wanted them to
play it safe as far as what songs they
released and Bohemian Rhapsody how can
you possibly even do a song like that's
completely off the grid they took
chances Queen did and now to see this
and Robbie Malik obviously is not a late
Bobby ballock I don't think he would
stand for this I I I'm pretty sure he
wouldn't if I believe that the portrayal
that I saw in that movie uh so yeah to
say all right that song never existed is
utterly ridiculous
well he's absolutely right uh we should
not pretend the song never existed we
should not erase the song from every
platform we shouldn't go look for a
Freddie Mercury statue to uh tear down
but but here's the good news none of
that is happening
okay it's all fake in fact Queen is not
canceled at all this song is not
canceled the entire story is fake this
is a lot of fake outrage over nothing as
it turns out
here's what's really happening
one single audio platform has decided to
start offering Queen's greatest hits
collection without that one song
that song has not been removed from the
greatest hits collection on every
platform on or on any platform except
for just this one
and the thing you should know about this
one platform where Fat Bottom Girls will
not be available is that it is
specifically an audio platform for
children the platform is called Yoto it
is an audio player without a screen that
plays music and audiobooks
now to give you an idea of the age range
this device is designed for here are
just three of the audiobook titles it
offers okay
Stuart Little Winnie the Pooh and Daniel
Tiger's Neighborhood five minute stories
in other words
this is a device not just for kids but
for very young kids
on its website the Yoda players are
listed with an age range of 3 to 12.
the company very specifically curates
material that is supposed to be
appropriate for preschool aged kids
and they judged that Fat Bottom Girls
probably isn't appropriate for that age
and they left it off which to me seems
extremely reasonable
and certainly not worth an outraged
segment on Fox News
are you ready to discover the incredible
benefits of a good night's sleep it's
time to awaken your senses and embrace
the importance of restful Slumber dive
into the world of sleep and introduce
yourself to an amazing product that
could revolutionize your nighttime
routine beam dream is a game changer
their dream powder a hot cocoa designed
specifically for Sleep could transform
your nights with flavors like cinnamon
cocoa and chocolate peanut butter that
make it a treat to sip on on to sip on
before bedtime dream contains a powerful
all-natural blend even including
magnesium to help you fall asleep stay
asleep and help you wake up refresh just
mix beam dream into hot water milk stir
froth and enjoy before bedtime every
night your body of mind deserves the
gift of restful nights try beams
best-selling dream powder get up to 40
off for a limited time when you go to
shopbeam.com Walsh news code Walsh check
out that's
shopbeam.com Welsh and use code Walsh
for up to 40 off now
I can't vouch for this platform at all
really to be clear I mean they may well
have books and other songs that I would
not consider appropriate for little kids
I have no idea either way I haven't
checked in fact if anything the real
problem here is not that they excluded
that one queensong but that they are
including every other Queen song
you know there are some other Queen
songs I can think of off the top of my
head that I wouldn't want my kids
singing along to especially when they're
three years old but that's not the point
the point is that that people
conservative especially
are apparently angry that a song called
Fat Bottom Girls is not being made
available for three-year-olds on a
children's audio device
a song by the way that contains these
lyrics okay this is the song that Fox
News is subset that they're not going to
play for kids
uh is these are the lyrics
I was just a skinny lad never knew no
good from bad but I knew life before I
left my Nursery left alone with big fat
Fanny she was such a naughty Nanny Heap
big woman you made a bad boy out of me
oh won't you take me home tonight down
beside your red fire light and you give
it all you got Fat Bottom Girls you make
the rock and roll go around
now
if this sounds like this is a song about
an overweight Nanny molesting a child in
the nursery that's because that's
exactly what the song is about okay that
is the song it's not a hidden message
there's nothing subtle about it
Freddie Mercury is singing about a kid
in a nursery being made into a quote Bad
Boy by a quote naughty nanny
who also happens to be big and fat
okay you don't need to read the lyrics
upside down and backwards or search for
invisible ink in between lines to
understand what's happening in the song
it's it's very clear
it's not cancel culture to suggest that
perhaps we wouldn't want a five-year-old
to go around singing along to those
kinds of lyrics
and in fact even if you take out the
extremely clear and undeniable
references to child molestation still
the song is vulgar and stupid okay even
if it was just a song about having sex
with women with large butts which seems
to be what most people assume it still
would clearly be inappropriate content
for young kids
and I say that not because I'm
politically correct but because I'm
something called a parent
now I understand that the song was made
50 years ago which by sheer passage of
time makes it a classic
but despite what wistful Boomers might
tell you not everything that pop culture
produced in the 60s and 70s was an
artistic Masterpiece that we should
teach our kids
in fact
a lot of the stuff from that era was
degenerate and stupid it doesn't
suddenly become brilliant once it
reaches the 50-year mark you read you
heard the lyrics again putting aside all
the child molestations of which is kind
of hard to put aside but these are just
dumb lyrics this is not sub this is this
is a masterpiece this is true Art Kids
if you heard that exact same song today
and it didn't exist at any other point
before you would hear that song and say
this is the dumbest freaking song I've
ever heard in my life
yet it happened it was made 50 years ago
and suddenly so it's a classic this is
amazing this is real music
cardi B's music is incredibly gross and
bad today in the year 2070 it'll be
considered a classic an oldie from
simpler times
but it'll still be still be gross and
bad
and in fact this is an important point
that is so often lost if you Lament The
degeneracy and stupidity of current pop
culture you should realize that current
pop culture didn't fall out of the sky
one day or come lumbering out of the
ocean like a twerking Godzilla no it is
the end result of a process that can be
traced back to the 70s and before it's
all part of the same heritage
pop artists today like to sing very dumb
and crass songs about sex bands like
Queen paved the way with their own very
dumb and crass songs about sex
it doesn't make sense to be offended by
Fat Bottom Girls if you think that WAP
is a musical Masterpiece that's true and
I've heard a lot of people pointing that
out well you're offended by Fat Bottom
Girls but what about whop
okay and anyone who likes but thinks
fat Bomb Girls is offensive uh you're
right you got a good point
but it also doesn't make sense to be
offended by WAP if you think that Fat
Bottom Girls was a musical masterpiece
that doesn't make sense either
now artists back then were actual
musicians they actually composed the
music they played the instruments Which
is far more than than we can say for pop
artists today but these artists
including the artist in Queen were also
for the most part drugged out sex craze
Godless degenerate pervert heathens
explicitly promoting that kind of
Lifestyle to their listeners
we should at least be honest about that
rather than acting like current pop
culture came out of nowhere is if there
was no precedent for any of this stuff
but then again Boomers in general like
to look around at the culture today and
pretend that we are that we are not
living in exactly the world that they
created
so this is in keeping with that theme
they Lament The vulgarity of modern
music while also lamenting that Fat
Bottom Girls isn't being placed into a
catalog alongside Winnie the Pooh
it's totally absurd
and that is ultimately why the people
complaining about Queen getting canceled
when queen in fact is not getting
canceled
are today canceled if you'd like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt Walsh Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed